Okay, so I was tasked to present the updated in-mind analysis, and this is a study of
tafacitimab, lenalidomide, and rituximab in relapsed refractory follicular lymphoma.
We will be doing a focused analysis looking at the clinical characteristics and outcomes by age.
So the incidence of follicular lymphoma increases with age, as we all know,
and most patients will eventually develop relapsed refractory disease requiring
sequential therapies. Tafacitimab is a humanized monoclonal antibody CD19-directed,
and it is approved in combination with lenalidomide and rituximab for relapsed
refractory follicular lymphoma. In the primary analysis of in-mind, tafa with R-squared
demonstrated a significant improvement in PFS compared to placebo with R-squared,
and this was associated with a 50%.
In the secondary analysis of in-mind, tafacitimab showed a 27% reduction in the risk of progression
or death. The safety profile in in-mind essentially showed that the addition of
tafacitimab was consistent with the known toxicities of R-squared-based therapy.
So the objective of this study was to perform a post hoc analysis of efficacy and safety in patients
with FL who were treated in the in-mind trial,
and to find out if they had been treated in the in-mind trial or not.
So just a quick reminder, in-mind was a Phase III double-blind randomized placebo-controlled
international multi-center trial. Eligible patients were 18 years and older. They had to
have relapsed refractory CD19-positive and CD20-positive follicular lymphoma, grades 1 to 3A,
and they also needed to have at least one prior systemic therapy, including an anti-CD20 monoclonal
antibody. Patients who were treated in the in-mind trial were 18 years and older. They had to have
relapsed refractory CD20-positive and CD20-positive follicular lymphoma, grades 1 to 3A, and they also
needed to have at least one prior systemic therapy, including an anti-CD20 monoclonal antibody.
Patients were randomized in a one-to-one ratio to receive either
tafacitimab or placebo with R-squared for up to 12, 28-day cycles.
Patients who had moderate renal insufficiency, and this was defined as a creatinine clearance
of 30 to less than 60, were also eligible to participate in this study. And for those patients,
the starting lenalidomide dose was reduced at 10 milligrams daily.
So the clinic
clinical characteristics and outcomes were analyzed by predefined age subgroups,
less than 65 versus 65 years and older, less than 75 versus 75 years and older,
and 65 and older versus less than 75 years.
Efficacy endpoints included PFS and time to next treatment, and the safety assessments included
the incidence and severity of treatment emergent AEs, and that included any events that led to
discontinuation, dose delays or interruptions, or dose reductions.
So here we see the baseline characteristics. Overall, 548 FL patients participated in InMind,
273 received the TAPA-containing arm, and 275 received the placebo-containing arm.
Across both treatment arms, 50% of the patients were 65 years and older,
and 20% were 75 years and older. In the 75 years and older age subgroup,
those patients had a higher proportion of ECOG performance status of 1 to 2,
moderate renal insufficiency, and a LPI score of 3 or higher.
So the mean relative dose intensity of tafacitimab was similar across all age subgroups.
Lenalidomide exposure was decreased in patients who were 75 years and older,
but it was still generally comparable across creatinine clearance subgroups within each age
category. In respects to efficacy, we do see an improved PFS and time to next treatment with
tafacitimab in patients less than 65 years and older. In the 75 years and older age subgroups,
the mean relative dose intensity of tafacitimab was similar across all age subgroups. Lenalidomide exposure was
decreased in patients who were 65 years and older. In respects to efficacy, we do see an improved
PFS and time to next treatment with tafacitimab in patients less than 65 years and older.
Improved median PFS with tafacitimab was also observed across all age subgroups.
And here we see the safety outcomes by age subgroup.
The observed toxicities were consistent with the known safety profile of these agents
across all subgroups. There were no new safety signals identified in any subgroup.
So to conclude, in the 70 years and older age subgroup, the mean relative dose intensity of
tafacitimab was reduced. In this post hoc analysis of the InMind trial,
TAFA with R-squared reduced the risk of progression or death irrespective of age,
including patients up to 88 years and even those with moderate renal impairment.
The safety profile was manageable and consistent across age subgroups. There
were no new safety signals identified. So to summarize, TAFA R-squared represents a
standard of care option for relapsed refractory FL. It demonstrates consistent efficacy and tolerability.
So I'd like to thank the patients, the family, the investigators who participated in InMind,
this was clearly a global effort. Thank you.